j'ai plus l'air et on se retrouvera la
place des arts ici c'est une simple vous
allait enregistrer une émission spéciale
l'histoire de mes chansons êtes l'auteur
sans flagornerie dit mais certaines des
plus belles chansons québec flagorner
mon cher la gagne dans tout votre
répertoire qu'elle était la chanson la
plus populaire la plus payante lorsque
vous regardez vos droits d'auteur qui
rentre à chaque année ça doit être
génial 23 décembre et douze postulants
paul
[Musique]
certainement à marche du coup elle était
beaucoup chanté de céline dion à la
serbie parce que c'est une chanson qui
laisse beaucoup d'espacé aux chanteurs
c'est des chansons n'ose poser ses
discours en face d'un corset le chanteur
pour beaucoup se promener avec avec mes
blues passent pu dans porte les
chanteurs occupent les haies et faut
croire que l'émotion qu'il est bien pour
le meilleur et pour le pire est en
progrès alors petit toit tentant de
confinement mes blues passent pu dans
après c'est vraiment unique de
circonstance vous avez signé cinq des
onze chansons du premier disque de beau
dommage
question est discrète je sais que c'est
comme des enfants on peut vraiment dire
mais votre préférée sur ce premier
disque est oui sans doute montréal parce
que c'était un petit peu comme je n'aime
pas l'expression même un maxima de
commerce
autrement dit rapidement s'est aussi mis
à dire de beau dommage c'était c'est
raymond réaliste c'est le montréalais
s'étaient de respecter notre langage
populaire et les lieux il avait les to
back
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
très organique même à la batterie réal
desrosiers pierre bertrand
on voit couper le souffle et des
compagnons de route des chambres est une
famille en fait c'est ce qui est bien
c'est qu'un cas les petits l'amitié
précède le métier soit parce que robert
léger ou piratage soit 6,2 sur le biais
de tous les gens que je connaissais à 20
la forme est beau dommage si les
chansons qui ont développé le bordel
c'est des bases plus ses succès était
tout à fait naturel qu'un jour les
principaux auteurs une chaire a vécu mon
dieu on partage des choses on sait je
dirai pas ce que ça va vite et bien je
suis content si on dit toujours comme
dans un groupe où ça va mal soit
cailleteau d'argent quand ils ne passent
et je veux parler d'un des plus gros
album de rock du québec traversions f1
de ben aknoun signé la presque totalité
de la dette
moi ce qui m'impressionne de certaines
chansons là dessus en trop je chante
comme un colosse
je le revois canard hôpitaux et ce qu'on
dirait que c'est gerry boulet qui a
écrit ses chansons m
est ce que vous vous êtes mis dans sa
roue pour écrire des coups tu touches à
quelque chose de ces crimes j'ai
toujours l'origine de la vie et des gens
jettent avec pauline julien comme qui a
trempé et quand il ya des gens qui avec
qui je refusais travail c'est de dire
qu'est ce que j'ai un commerce
stationnement cégeps des cercles
concentriques
quand j'écris mes temps avec lui chez
lui à l'essai de son talent fait masser
100% c'est de complicité et cahiers déjà
ça tienne un peu surface et jerry aussi
de trouver une place où ce pari ou avec
breen leboeuf et une place où se rejoint
et des personnes se rejoignent en
mettant dans lifestyle gélas changement
précisé m elle n'a pas suivi le rythme
mais c'était de dire de ces ma job de
capter la sensibilité des jeunes plus à
l'ouest que je comprends pas votre
parcours c'est qu'après avoir écrit
certaines des plus grandes chansons du
répertoire québécois
vous avez décidé à 81 vraiment fondé le
magazine crown travailler sur surplus
surprises aussi
et si vous marchez avec la chanson ses
démons en juin je répondrai simplement
je t'ai pas fourchette la chanson c'est
qu'il est arrivé quelque chose
d'important dans ma vie envie demain ma
femme et moi ne peut jeunes enfants est
très bas âge et je me suis mis à écrire
un texte là dessus un texte choisi qui
était plutôt et j'avançais dans cette
demande et non sur la mort d'un petit
tri et aimant et je me suis dit est ce
que je vois pied bertrand michel rivard
ou gerry boulet l'homme qui tu veux
entendre chanter ça non j'ai quand même
perdu confiance en chanson je ne pouvais
pas dire les choses qui tel un fond de
mon coeur est pensé que ce chantier même
par mes meilleurs amis les meilleurs
interprètes au monde j'ai j'avais un
blocage mais il fallait pas forcer la
note qu'en beau dommage se regrouper
pour la plupart disent que j'appelle des
pieds on lui voit marcher je suis pas
arrivé à faire des chansons en fait tenu
une deux qui sont sur l'intégration
qu'on rajoute des tonnes qui ont pris
2010 la mechta mêmes blocages jaliens
studio que j'allais à mort à n'être que
d'autres je suis content de 500 jetons
avec mes amis mais moi je vais ce
blocage
quand l'inspiration dire venu parce que
la dernière touche déco résister pour le
spectacle la fête nationale où vous
deviez écrire une chanson thème et je
voyais au travail avec votre stylo votre
papier l'énergie la flamme dans mon jeu
télé la chanson était très très bien
c'est gentil c'est gentil oui c'est
revenu qui est venu jouer à espérer que
si elle venue avec la même qualité mais
interpress je peux dire ça y en a qui
sont plus lents comme jerry il est des
gens comme michel pas se débrouille très
bien
alors là j'ai à faire leurs exercices de
trouver des mots dits jeunes avec streit
oui je pense que les lieux la ferme est
un troll thierry est je vous souhaite
plein de belles chansons merci pour
casser
[Musique]
à
oh